you ready you guys ready making sure you
say wow okay
[Music]
my name is my son
and we make fresh mozzarella for the
city of new york
this is the mozzarella card get a piece
of card like that
do a cut through the guitar and make
them small pieces
because if you do this warm it up with
hot water from the
sink put some salt give it a little
taste
because every day skirt is different
[Music]
okay how are you guys ready now we gotta
come with a big pad
from someone like he's been doing for 26
years so i can say the hardest part
is that knowing what's enough water
what's not once you put too much hot
water in it messes it up
it's my feeling you see now they started
melt already
it looks like that what i put was just
right
[Music]
it's actually unbelievable sometimes hot
water and a paddle
can create something like this because
it just became a work of art
okay now we're ready for this shot
because i'm pulling up now
[Music]
okay now carlo be making the bocconcini
mozzarella
the main thing that some people
understand is as you can see we're not
wearing gloves
everything is clean but there's no way
possible that you can make mozzarella
with gloves because the material is so
hot
it'll melt the plastic and you can't get
the feel of the touch
when art you sculpt you design and you
start from scratch on the canvas so for
me this is an italian culture of art
displayed through food
i have the best job in the world from
1993 to now
it's 24 years you feel good when people
appreciate what you're doing
they treat them like i'm god i'm not i'm
just making myself let's say
[Music]
you know everyone has an idol right some
people like derek jeter some people like
carmel anthony
not many people can say like their
father's their idol
to see from what he drove in 1993
until he drives now not that it matters
but to see the sacrifice he put in
to see on christmas he would sleep in
the store in the basement
just to make the extra mozzarella people
from italy come here and say
i've never had mozzarella like this in
my life that makes this for me coming
every day
satisfying i'm happy that is my fault
this to me is like a story and a work of
art and a canvas
that's too beautiful to not keep using
as a canvas
that's what makes me hungry and
determined
to keep this because at the end i feel
like as great as this is
there's another chapter and i want to be
that person to write that chapter for
when he's done
[Music]
you